Cause you think,
Lord,
I thought appears in your hand.
Right?
That's obvious Pedang.
It's it.
It's nothing you ever ask about.
But what the hell does that mean?
I thought appears in your hand.
What kind of ridiculous explanation is that?
You know,
it just doesn't help with anything.
Where does it come from?
Well,
nowhere.
It just appears in my head.
Okay,
well that's not a very sophisticated explanation as it turns out,
you know?
And so you might think that those thoughts,
thoughts that you think,
well,
where do they come from old?
They're often someone else's thoughts,
right?
Someone Long Dad,
that might be part of it.
Just like the words you use to think our utterances of people who've been long
dead.
And so you're informed by the spirit of your ancestors.
That's one way of looking at it.
And your motivation,
speak to your motion,
speak to in your body,
speaks to you.
And it all does all that,
at least in part through the dream.
And the dream is the birthplace of the fully articulated idea.
They don't just come from nowhere.
Fully fledged,
right?
They have a development,
Laura Jun and God only knows how,
how long,
how lengthy that origin is.
Even to say something like,
I am conscious,
you know,
that's taken PE chimpanzees,
don't say that.
You know,
it's been 7 million years since we broke from chimpanzees.
Something like that from the common ancestor.
You know,
they have no articulated knowledge at all.
They have very little self representation in some sense and very little self
consciousness.
And that's not the case with us at all.
And we had to painstakingly figure all of this out during that,
you know,
7 million year voyage.
And I think some of that's represented and and,
and,
and captured in some sense in these ancient stories,
which I believe were part of,
especially the oldest stories in genesis,
which is the stories we're going to start with that they were at that,
that some of the archaic nature of the human being is encapsulated in those
stories.
And it's very,
very instructive as far as I can tell.
I can give you just a quick example.
You know,
there's an idea of sacrifice in,
in,
in the Old Testament,
and it's pretty barbaric.
You know,
I mean,
the story of Abraham and Isaac,
there's a good example of that because Abraham was called on to actually
sacrifice his own son,
which doesn't really seem like something that a reasonable God would ask you to
do.
Right.
And the God in the Old Testament is frequently cruel and arbitrary and demanding
and paradoxical and which,
which is one of the things that really gives the book life because it wasn't
edited by a committee,
you know,
a committee that was concerned with,
with,
uh,
Nardo offending anyone,
that's for sure.